i believe there is going to be some more
show from mom nature later today now
this is a live picture from our camera
on top of the malasky family of
companies downtown with obviously the
strat and the msg sphere coming right
along but a stormy looking sky there
have been a couple of showers around and
since we last spoke just a couple of
minutes ago the national weather service
has expanded that flood watch to include
all of clark county parts of
northwestern arizona southwestern utah
and lincoln county now you got to
remember a flash flood watch means
simply
watch out for the possibility there's
been so much rain that if there is rain
it could cause additional flooding so
let's go over the radar pictures again
just in the last hour there was a brief
sprinkle maybe even some lightning that
went through oh maybe around bishop
gorman high school down towards
mountain's edge on the bigger picture
you get the idea that the rain has been
mostly to the south of us traveling from
the east to the west there's plenty of
juice in the atmosphere we're going to
check out the futurecast in just a
moment remember it's 87 out of read
international temperatures all over the
place not just here in our neighborhoods
from the upper 80s along the west side
of town to 94 in henderson but the upper
80s in seven hills and to nevada and
beyond it's not very often that you have
pa-rump and baby warmer than laughlin
there's definitely been some rain in
kingman at 76 degrees the temperature
usually drops around these severe storms
so we'll try for a high of 99 but that
sounds pretty much like a stretch at 87
right now the normal high for this time
of year 104. so this is the futurecast
what we were just looking at a minute
ago is the actual radar futurecast is a
projection of where clouds and rain may
be in the next hour not much going on to
the west of us not much in the afternoon
by three it looks like more storms up
over northwestern arizona as we get
through the afternoon and the evening
perhaps seven o'clock this evening a
much better chance for rain even again
at eight o'clock clearing out but it may
be very active overnight tonight into
tomorrow morning for your family and
friends we are seeing some more rain
over eastern kentucky it doesn't appear
to be as severe as the rain that caused
all the flooding there okay your most
accurate eight day forecast
maybe only the mid 90s again tomorrow it
will clear out over the weekend before
the next round of storms brings better
chances for additional monsoon storms
next week ted florento along with the
updates for you this afternoon john